when you jump into season one of
american horror story
what were your expectations of that when
did it click that
this was going to be like an epic empire
i never know i st my brain doesn't
really work in that way of thinking oh
this is going to be a hit this is the
thing
it's really like i want to play her i
want to work with that person you know
and and like david milch and then
certainly like ryan murphy who has
changed my life and continues to change
my life
every single day in so many ways um
but i was at the time doing a play i was
doing a play at williamstown i was doing
a doll's house with sam gold
and ryan called me and said i've written
this
arc on my new show american horror story
she's called nora and it was wild
because i was playing nora and
i i don't think he knew that at the time
so it was just like he's some kind of
seer uh which he is um
and i i was going straight from doll's
house into
seminar which was a play i did on
broadway with hamish linklater
he's in the other room and um and alan
rickman
and uh wonder hedy and park and jerry
o'connell and it was
um also with sam gold directing
and um i was like brian of course i want
to do this but i'm
i'm about to go into rehearsals for this
play and he said well
when is your day off and i said well
once we start performances
we we only have mondays we and he said
oh that's fine
and i was like but but it's in new york
and you're not he said yeah that's fine
i'll figure it out
and i so playing norah on american
horror story i would do my matinee
in seminar they would have a car outside
the theater
get in the car go to the airport fly to
la
sleep for a few hours go to set shoot
all of my nora
stuff that they could in one day and
then on monday night go
and take the red eye back to new york
and be back on stage tuesday and then
that three
it was originally gonna be i think three
episodes and then i think nora ended up
this is gonna be wrong but like in nine
episodes or something
and they just kept doing it and no one
else on the planet could
figure something out like that but ryan
did and um
so that was my that was my first
experience of
of of being a part of the show and then
for season two
he said now for this one i i need you to
stay
in l.a is that okay and i said yes of
course absolutely that's okay
that one's a heavy roll i can understand
that so but that was the sort of
uh and then it's just been you know it's
just that show is such a gift
um going into just the idea of doing
that like craziness of going back and
forth i imagine that was that was very
taxing and exhausting but what would you
say could be
a pro of operating like that is there
any benefit
yes i think uh i think
that the roles that i was playing
because i loved both of them so much
were so
energizing they really felt like
nourishment
so even though i was probably very
depleted in terms of sleep i
actually felt very well nourished
because i loved
my work so much and um
and so i really mean that like i could
feel it sort of in my veins that i was
getting like vitamin infusions from the
roles that i was playing
and um and i also think there is
something to
when you are wildly busy
and probably a bit exhausted uh
creatively i find that wonderful things
can come out of that
i'm not recommending that people you
know don't take care of themselves and
don't sleep
by any stretch especially now as a
mother i'm like sleep and eating all
those things
but and i am someone who worries about
things but there was no time for that
so i had no choice but to be incredibly
present uh
in both in everything i was doing and
i think that was of great value and and
there is something
something to that even if it's not
sustainable maybe like for
you know but that sounds a little like
uh like
our film festival grind being around and
just covering
as much as possible without sleeping and
i thrive
i thrive in that zone and then when it's
done do you sleep for a week
and then i come home and crash i sleep
uh unusually long hours for like three
weeks after that
yeah so i'm not let i'm not letting you
leave the american horror story topic
without
one attempt at a season 10 tease i don't
know what what is
i know you probably can't talk about it
much at all but what is something that
you might get to do in american horror
story season 10 that you've never
had the chance to do on that show before
oh gosh i can say that the person i'm
playing on this on this season
is is nothing like anyone i've
played on the show before and i am
having such a
wonderful time with her and and uh
with my fellow actors and um i love
this season i love this season i i
i think new fans of the show will love
this season but i really
the longtime fans of the show i just
can't wait to share this season with
them
um yeah there's something
there's something about it it's really
there's i wish i could say more but i i
really love i wish i
yeah i i just i've been playing this
game for nine seasons now that was a
very uh respectable response right there
you